قبل بدايه حلقتنا امس بدقائق وضمن الجوله
الثانيه من مرحله المجموعات تفوق المنتخب
المغربي على بلجيكا بهدفين مقابل لا شيء
في فوز تاريخي وفرح ملايين في المغرب
والعالم العربي وطبعا كثير ناس فرحوا بهذا
الفوز المستحق والاداء المشرف من وقتها
وللان الاحتفالات ما وقفت في العالم
الافتراضي فهاشتاق المغرب وبلجيكا ترند
ومليان صور ومقاطع وتغريدات ومنشورات
احتفاليه غير طبعا الاحتفالات في الشوارع
المغرب وخارج المغرب ايضا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
مو بس لاعبين المنتخب
ووالده اللاعب اشرف حكيمي واللي كان لها
صور بعد الفوز مع ابنها وتفاعل الناس كثير
بشكل كبير مع هذه الصور اللقطات بيظهر
فيها اشرف هو رايح يحتفل مع والدته بعد
انتهاء المباراه والناس تفاعلت مع الصور
كثير واللي بيظهر فيها مدى فخر الام
بابنها وسعادته وجودها الى جانبه ايضا ومع
تفاعل الناس مع هذه الصور كمان اعاده
تداول تصريحات قديمه لاشرف بيتكلم فيها عن
خلفيه المتواضعه وبقول انه ما بيخجل من
ماضي ومن والده كان بائع متجول والدته
بتعمل في البيوت وانهم اتعذبوا من اجله
وضحوا علشان يتدرب ويلعب كوره واليوم هم
مصدر طاقته وحماسه لان الام ام في كل
الظروف فمع الاحتفال خلال مكان اشرف
بيخلعتي شيرته للاحتفاظ في
الكاميرات والدته وهي ايضا
بتساعده اشرف تفعل مع الصور اللي شفتوها
وشاركها على حساباته وعنوانها باحبك امي
وحتى حساب الفيف الرسمي ما كان بعيد عن
التاثر بهذه الصور فنشرها هو كمان وعلق
حماس وامومه وبنوه وقبله مغربيه في حب
الوطن بعض الانتصار التاريخي امام بلجيكا
اشرف حكيمي ووالدته كان النجم اليوم امام
عدسات المصورين